great thanks a lot
so I'm gonna be talking about something
I'm sorry uh after this you are going to
have a break and then we are going to
have a short break and after that we are
going to have a session where I'm going
to be showcasing uh three of our eight
uh
uh postdocs uh Simon's fellows for The
evolutionary biology program
all right so I'm going to be talking
about some aspects of bacterial growth
in fluctuating environments
um coming from experiments we've been
doing in the last couple of years
um and I'll try to highlight also some
theoretical sides of this but but most
of the talk will basically focus on on
experimental results and we'll sort of
go from systems biology of responses of
of bacteria and eventually towards small
populations
so
basically we've been measuring E coli
population Dynamics in singles it's a
single cell resolution where we can
track all the individuals in a
population while controlling the
environment so that's the the kind of
experiments we set out to do
and today I'm going to talk about
three aspects of that that we've been
studying one is the responses that you
see when you expose cells to fluctuating
sugars
then I'm going to talk about the
statistics of the lineages that you see
in small populations in constant
environments and at the end I'm going to
talk about what this looks like when you
have small populations that are
experiencing fluctuating stresses
so we the device we're using we was
built by a postdoc in the lab guillaum
Lambert and all most of the work I'm
going to talk about today was done by
Guillaume and this is really a
modification of something that's called
the mother machine and that was invented
in 2010 by suck Jun it's a microfluidic
device in which you can grow single
cells of e coli in small lines such that
the mother cell remains trapped and you
just continue to observe cell divisions
for long periods of time and so we
thought this would be a great device for
doing a fluctuating environment
experiments with single cell tracking if
we could expand those chambers and make
them slightly larger so that we have
small populations
so that in principle the effective the
population size here is larger than one
cell but it's not it's certainly still a
small population and so the device works
in the following way you have a flow of
nutrients that brings in which is which
is bringing in
um nutrients
and also taking away cells
and the nutrients get into these
Chambers purely by diffusion and the
nutrients we're bringing in are small
sugars so the diffusion time and the
turnover time of the chemical
composition of these Chambers is on the
order of a few seconds and we can
actually measure this by flowing in
small fluorescent molecules so we can
basically feed all these cells happily
and watch the cell divisions here so I'm
going to show you just a couple of
examples of oec so the chamber sizes you
can see sort of from the size of E coli
which here are roughly one to two
microns in sizes it's minimal medium
they're growing on pure glucose and so
the cell size is roughly between one and
two microns if you grow them in Rich
conditions the cells get larger
and so in this uh in this experiment
we're following five separate
populations
and constant glucose and then we're just
going to fluctuate after four hours to
no glucose at all so here you're
watching cell divisions
for four hours now you fluctuate to no
glucose and still stop dividing and once
you supply glucose again they continue
to divide and you can keep these cells
in focus for long periods of time and
track all the cells and continue this
kind of experiment
we can also do other things like
stressing the cells by giving them
pulses of antibiotics so in this case
we're giving pulses of carbonyl
short pulses and every time you have a
pulse you kill cells these are 20 minute
pulses and so the population can still
continue dividing because the rate of
growth in the times in which there's no
antibiotic is sufficient to maintain a
population size and we're going to talk
about this Dynamics a little bit later
so the first thing we we started looking
at is what happens when you change the
carbon source that the cells are growing
on
and so this really goes back to some
pioneering the experiments at the
beginning of Gene regulation which were
done by Mono
um
in bacteria and Minnows observations are
well known if you shift bacteria from
one carbon source to another typically
the cells have to go through a lag and
eventually this led to the discovery of
Gene regulation so basically in this
experiment he was growing cells on pure
rabinose if he switches them to glucose
it turns out they don't go to relax so
they already have the Machinery to
digest glucose instead of the grow
exponentially in glucose essentially
immediately if you switch from one sugar
source to another like if you switch to
xylose then you go through some lag and
eventually the cells after in this case
two to three hours they are able to
recover full growth exponential growth
also this is another well-known
observation if you grow them in mixtures
of two carbons they preferentially
digest the glucose so the more glucose
you give the cells to they rise to a
higher density before plateauing and the
length of this Plateau depends very much
on which sugars are involved but typical
typical time skills here are one to two
hours depending on the carbon source so
we can
repeat this in our
device and so now if we grow cells in
glucose you see them growing we're going
to fluctuate the lactose
right there the cells stop dividing for
about an hour
and then they can resume growth
so that's a single fluctuation from
glucose to lactose and what goes on
actually in in the cells here is that
the cells are turning on the genes to
metabolize lactose
so we can in this case quantify things
even without tracking single cells we
can simply look how many how fast are
cells pushing past a specific
cross-section of this device and use
that as a proxy for the elongation rate
of the population and so if you plot
this cell speed of just pure pushing
keep in mind this is just cells
elongating and pushing against each
other you're going to see in glucose
that you're in some uh
some
pushing State here some equilibrium
cell speed and then when you fluctuate
to lactose you basically go directly to
zero there's no cell growth at all and
after about 30 minutes you can now
slowly resume growth and it takes about
50 minutes to get back to normal
and now the cells can grow happily in
lactose
so that's a single fluctuation
and what we did is we continued this so
we always see this lag in recovery we
continue this now in fluctuating
environments so we do four hours of
lactose followed by four hours glucose
and we continue to fluctuate
and what you see in this case is that
the lag which you initially encountered
disappears so the next time you
encounter lactose you never go through
lags and the cells can now comfortably
grow on both glucose and lactose in this
fluctuating environment
so the time scale here is four hours of
glucose four hours of lactose and in
this condition the cells are growing
with a rate of cell division which is an
hour which means that in four hours the
cells have gone four cell divisions so
if you think of this as a small
population you have basically four
generations between these fluctuate
environments so what this suggests is
that the cells can remember
the past through Fourier cell divisions
I think they're growing essentially as
fast as they were just in like the just
in glucose yeah
yeah that was also surprising
so now we can play with these time
scales of how long you grow between
exposures and look at this memory so
we vary the time since the lactose
exposure and I showed you that at four
hours you have no growth delay and the
second exposure so that's perfect memory
we call that phenotypic memory there's
no lag of recovery phase in this case
and that's true if you fluctuate
certainly faster now if you go longer
than four hours then you start
forgetting the cells start forgetting
that they've already seen lactose and
clearly if you grow them for very long
periods of time glucose they completely
forget that they see lactose and so they
have to go through a complete lag again
and so that's this kind of same size
eventually it will be of the same size
if you dilute if you let them grow for
long long periods of time
the lag phase is the dead time where you
absolutely do not grow and there there's
a slow right so this is how these these
curves uh basically this is the
forgetting right this is the complete
forgetting of memory so if you estimate
well I mean this is really the the curve
but you could say that you know you're
going to see a significant difference
between you know cells which have never
seen lactose because we've grown for
many many generations without lactose
and
um 12 hours of growth there is still
some some difference here so roughly it
seems that some part of this memory can
persist through up to 10 generations and
here we see that you get really perfect
memory for four generations
mm-hmm
so what is the basis of this memory and
I oh yeah
yeah so that's a
that's this kind of experiment basically
so what I was just plotting was the the
time to recover after the second glucose
exposure
mm-hmm
so we went through the molecular side of
this I I was going to just briefly
mention it we I can certainly say more
about the molecular details but it's
good to just get a sense for what can
provide this kind of memory in the cells
the key genetic Network here is the Lac
operon which turns on the genes to
metabolize lactose and
and that network has been studied in
immense detail
the key Gene for metabolizing lactose is
called Lac Z
beta galactosidase the gene for bringing
in the protein that brings in lactose is
called the Lac Premiere slack y
these are produced off of a single
messenger RNA and these genes are
repressed by a protein that's called Lac
eye which is the Lac repressor that
protein when it senses lactose in
particular it senses allo lactose but
that's a Side Story it falls off of DNA
and it allows production of this operon
production of these genes there's a
positive feedback loop here because
permease is now produced brings in more
lactose which means that the probability
of a binding of lack of pressure
increases and you have this powerful
positive feedback loop which then
rapidly turns this gene on so
what provides memory in this system uh
we find that in fact the lack proteins
themselves are the memory so the cells
maintain the proteins they in particular
lack Z and Lac y each provide memory
they provide different parts of this
memory lacks the impact on its own can
completely eliminate lags we should see
that here and lack wine if you already
provide it it shortens these lags and we
can also follow in single cells by
labeling
fluorescently labeling the permease we
can we can actually see the Dynamics of
the permease in the cells and we can
actually see that if you have enough
time of course you dilute this permease
okay and then you have to go through a
full lag but if you make faster
fluctuations you never fully dilute this
and that apparently is sufficient to
maintain growth
so the proteins themselves are super
stable proteins they're degradation
times and their own are in the one week
time scale which means that the only
reason that that you see dilution here
is not because of active degradation
with proteins but just because of cell
growth and elongation yeah why does the
cell turn this thing off anyway I mean
even if it doesn't get the the other
kind of sugar it could keep it on
running what's the cost of it having to
turn it off if it just gets too cold
yeah so so those costs have been have
been measured and
um it depends sensitively on the
conditions that you're in but um people
have measured costs for having this
operon on it depends on how much of it
it's on and it really has to do with the
fact that
um to bring in lactose the Lac premieres
actually uses the proton gradient
okay across the cell membrane so
for destroying that gradient is not good
for the cell in general so
okay
so this this phenotypic memory as you
can see is useful for fluctuations which
are on intermediate time scales one to
ten Generations we're estimating here
now we also found this memory I'm not
going through I'm not going to show
these results but just tell you that we
found this memory also in other sugar
operons so for lactose galactose
arabinose maltose in all these cases you
have this kind of phenotypic matter
so next we asked okay so that gives you
intermediate scale what about if you now
fluctuate faster so imagine that before
you finished adapting to lactose
normally you go through this 30 minutes
of dead time and then this recovery
phase imagine at this point somewhere
you now fluctuated back to glucose and
you do faster fluctuations or even
imagine something more extreme before
you even left this lag phase you now
switch back to glucose and see what
happens
so in that case we actually find a
different kind of behavior I'll mention
this in a moment so what we see is when
you fluctuate from glucose to lactose
you go through this 30 minute dead time
now you go back to glucose you can
already grow in glucose okay and now
when you go back to lactose you can grow
perfectly well
so keep in mind you haven't seen lactose
here for 30 minutes but as far as the
lap operon you've somehow gone from zero
to per you know induction through the
glucose exposure if you go faster and
you see lactose for 10 minutes then
glucose by the time you see lactose next
you're already in the recovery phase you
see glucose
for another 10 minutes and by the time
you got lactose again you're perfectly
growing in lactose and you've only seen
lactose for a total of 20 minutes
okay so if you go through glucose
exposures you actually adapt you turns
out you adapt faster which which means
that the cells are remembering the
process of responding
so that's why we call this a response
memory
okay
so
so this result we can also look in at
the molecular side of it and I'm going
to go quickly through this but basically
we can give pulses of lactose and look
at how fast the cells turn on the genes
for the left operon and we see that
after you move lactose there's an
overshoot which Peaks after 40 minutes
so the cells continue to respond to
lactose even after you've removed it
from the medium for about 40 minutes and
that gives you this kind of response
memory and we can go further because in
the Lac Opera has been studied very very
well there's a lot of tools to play
around with it and we can show this
really boils down to the lap repressor
determining this response memory profile
so you can actually shift this response
memory profile by tuning by changing the
Affinity of the Lac repressor for DNA so
you can actually make it turn off faster
okay so it seems that that certainly the
properties of The Binding of the black
repressor can Canon principle be tuned
to give you different response memory
profiles
all right
okay so on this memory side we we see
that in in the fluctuating environments
you have two types of memory that can be
useful one is the spenacypic memory
which is this passive passing down of
proteins and that's useful on these
intermediate time scales and then you
can have response memory which would be
useful for faster fluctuations or pulses
so now to say something about the
implications of this if you think about
what determines gene expression levels
in Evolution how they evolve
typically people think about cost
benefits so the cost of producing the
protein versus the benefit of having it
when you need it here this adds another
layer to it because it could very well
be that you're actually over producing
the protein to some extent in any given
generation so that the progeny will
avoid lag phases and so incorporating
that into some analysis would also be
interesting is what are the implications
of having memory for
for the evolution of gene expression
profiles
okay so that was the first section on
responses to fluctuating sugars so now I
want to go go to the next step which is
that instead of just looking at at
growth rates we actually have a lot more
data in these devices we have all the
single cells and they're being tracked
so it'd be interesting to see what do
the statistics look when you look in
finer detail now at the kind of lineages
that you get yeah
you mentioned that it could be that it
is producing extra proteins
for the progenies or it could be just
the time lag
it could be just a timeline to get the
protein out so there could be an
inertial effect right it doesn't have to
be with any cause
is that what what happened yeah I mean
it's really a question of you know what
determines the gene expression levels
how are they set how do they evolve and
so what I'm what I'm saying here is that
there's another layer to it which is
that you know you may not just be
adapting to the here and now okay but
also your expression levels could be set
by the fact that they allow your progeny
to avoid uh going through longer legs
yeah so in terms of learning what you've
shown is that they're capable of
sensitization and you've got a very good
system in which you could try and
investigate whether they're actually
capable of associative learning to see
whether the bacteria can be classically
conditioned as far as I know the
simplest organism that can be
classically conditioned it's paramecium
and that's a debatable result right but
you could definitely easily track I've
got a couple of papers which show how
they could be a classically conditioned
so I'd really be interested to see if
you could do absolutely great
okay so so now to go into this uh
lineage
um
so I want to talk a little bit about the
branching process of cell divisions
um these are results I'm going to
discuss the next International slides
results from a slightly different device
in which we maintain even smaller
populations of 10 to 20 cells and we
track them and then I'll go back to our
our larger device in a bit so here we
really have single cell tracking of
these small populations of 10 to 20
cells
um
we're growing them in constant
conditions in minimal medium and we're
observing them for three and a half days
so that's about 100 generations of cell
divisions and this is the tree from one
one such population and so let me just
say what I mean by this tree if I zoom
in here
on this piece of data
then this is a tree and this shows you
when the cell is divided so the branch
lengths here is the cell division time
and every time a cell leaves this device
then the branch ends okay so this is not
death this is just flowing out of the
device
yeah it will eventually yeah
but doesn't the geometry then the bias
this
geometry of the device it certainly
could right so in spatial trees and
space will have different shapes right
that's true
um okay so so now we have this big tree
and the first thing we can do is ignore
the tree and just ask about the the
branch lengths which is really the cell
cycle
so this is the cell cycle distribution
of E coli in this particular condition
and I call that g of Tau and this is the
time between cell divisions observed in
every single cell in this population
which is about 1700 cell divisions
so
um this okay so so we have this
this distribution
um and and now we can ask so what about
the Visions if I look now into the tree
Okay so
I take a single cell lineage and what I
mean by that is I look at the cell and
now I just track it backwards and so it
goes through a number of cell divisions
back to its ancestor different cells
will have different
trajectories and of course over time
right we're gonna by coalescence we're
coalescing on to some some single
trajectory here which remains after long
times
so the question is correct the spine of
this is the inner chamber of the of your
of your so so actually in this case the
our device has the device I'm using here
has uh cells leaving from both sides
okay so it looks like this let's see so
the cells can go out either way and then
and so the that's right so the cells
that remain for a long time
um
well it depends on on where they moved
around
all right
Okay so
now he's like now what are the
statistics of cell divisions along this
this kind of lineage are they different
or are they the same exact statistics As
You observe in this G of Tau in the tree
so a lineage in isolation would be what
you get from the mother machine which is
basically trapping a single cell and
just observing divisions for a long long
period of time and in that case every
single cell comes from this G of Tau I
should tell you that there is
essentially no memory of these towers
between Generations so you can really
um to seemingly very good approximation
think of each one of these tabs as being
drawn independently from from the same G
of Tau okay people have measured that as
well so
okay so those would be a lineage and
isolation now you're in a population
okay and the question is do the lineages
in the population look different and so
this first thought you'd say Well
they're they're just independent right
so so maybe not but in fact you should
think that every time the cell divides
it makes a copy of the lineage
and so it turns out that if you uh
consider this you will see that in fact
there's optimal lineages which will
out-compete all others and let me just
say what I mean by that a little more
precisely you have this distribution G
of Tau
and so over long periods of time the
number of lineages which will have G of
Tau okay as their statistics right
because the lineages could have these
intervals arranged in any possible order
the number of such lineages is going to
grow as the entropy of this G of tap at
the same time if I deviate in my
statistics a little bit from this G of
Tau I'm going to have slightly fewer
lineages which I can compute how by by
how much my my special G of tau is moved
right but I might have slightly more
offspring every single lineage might be
represented with a higher number in the
population and that can also be computed
and so it turns out that what's going on
here is actually a trade-off between
exponential amplification all right and
the statistics of how many lineages
actually are there and so you can write
down this Optimum and so this takes the
flavor of a path integral and we can
compute what are these optimal lineages
and so their statistics in fact are G of
Tau modulated by an exponential that
kills the tail of this G of Tau at the
rate which is the growth rate of that
population
okay so we describe this theory in this
paper here
and then recently we actually measured
this in our in our device and we looked
at these lineages that we get and we we
measured the cell cycle age distribution
along the lineages that's the gray curve
here that's the data
and then we take the prediction from
single cell and isolation you see that
this red curve does not fit the data
particularly well and it certainly
doesn't fit the tail and then our
prediction for optimal lineages would be
this so keep in mind this is a
prediction it's not a fit it's simply
that g of Tau modulated by this
exponential so we can also see the
Dynamics of how long it takes to read
that to reach this and indeed you have
to wait a good number of generations to
get to this equilibrium
secretary this is a feature of sampling
from the Republic yes that's right
it checks your Independence assumption
that's correct because this would look
quite different correlation absolutely
short question about what you said about
the independence I'm a bit surprised
that this is
gold value in the exponential growth are
kind of like producing a you know
replicating their genome perfusion
divisions forward which you may expect
like an anti-correlation between
Generations on a short term or something
like that that's uh there is that a fact
right which is that in lb in Rich and
Rich medium the the cell division cycle
is such that you're already replicating
the DNA of the daughter and the
granddaughter in the same cell and so in
that case
I don't remember if there are
correlations this is minimal medium so
that's that's not happening in these
cells
okay
because anti-correlation has been the
two Offspring but that doesn't actually
that doesn't enter that's right
the uh the cells smell figure out how to
stay in the middle of those tubes they
would have a tremendous selective
Advantage right they would have a purely
spatial advantage that's correct so I
wonder if you might somehow be selecting
for a bacteria to figure out how to stay
in the middle of those two
that could happen if they could become
sticky somehow in our device but it
turns out they're not in fact they've
been knocked out all the genes for being
sticky have been knocked out in the
strain so we're trying to prevent them
from doing that there's three genes that
make them quite sticky
okay so so that's lineages in constant
environments
and that's that's basically the
statistics you expect
in the absence of selection so if you
don't have this is really just
statistics of branching
so now we can look also at small
populations under fluctuating stress and
what I mean in this case is going to be
antibiotics you saw we could we could
give them these pulses and let's take a
look at now we go back to our bigger
device because we want to be able to
somehow maintain the cells even despite
the fact that we're killing them so we
need slightly bigger devices
um and so this is a okay I don't I think
the background is as is a little blurry
here but in the back here are our
trajectories of 20 populations and this
this um red curve is the average and so
these populations and they're being
tracked are um growing to roughly a size
of about 50 or 60 cells here and then we
give them these little pulses of
carbonicillin
for 20 minutes and then you see that we
kill them and then they can recover back
in lb which is Rich medium and then we
kill them
Etc until it turns out they reach some
other stable equilibrium here
of course eventually they'll go extinct
but this is some other stable state that
persists
so now we look at
um
a few things in this population in this
case we track all the cells and so we
get this kind of picture and we have our
single cell statistics we can look at
statistics in single time slices or we
can go backwards and look at statistics
on lineages
so
what we find is quite interesting
if you look at this experiment and plot
again ignore the tree and just plot the
Single Cell statistics so for example
the age of division which is the G of
Tau I showed you before you get this
ground curve here you see it has two
peaks okay the first Peak is at around
just below 20 minutes
and then there's another Peak here and
what it turns out if you look in detail
in these movies is you see that cells
can actually grow extra large and then
they can make two divisions in Rapid
succession okay so that's what you get
here two divisions in Rapid succession
giving rise to cell division Ages which
are much faster than you'd expect right
for E coli which is supposed to divide
it every every 20 minutes so so that's
one feature of this distribution
if you look at elongation rates which is
just the rate at which the cells are
elongating in the population then you
see this kind of distribution here
okay
now if you look in the single lineages
the the lineages that that persist for
long periods of time on this device you
get a different distribution of this age
of division and you see that it
eliminates this tail it eliminates this
peak here
and if you look at the elongation rate
you see that it's in fact shifted to
slower elongation rate
so what we're seeing here is that in the
fluctuating condition which involves
pulses of antibiotics there the lineages
which which succeed are the ones that
were growing slightly slower
which is the opposite of what you'd
expect right and so the reason is so so
now now we have to think about what that
means so it seems there's an advantage
for slow slower growth I think it was
mentioned in one of the first talks you
know is it always good to divide quickly
and bacteria turns that turns out that
under different types of stresses it's
actually good to divide slowly so the
very well-known nice paper on this was
from Natalie Balaban in 2004 that showed
that there's this phenomenon of
persistor in E coli which are cells that
are basically not dividing they're
dividing very very slowly and if you
look at these movies you see most cells
are going fast except for these slow
guys and then you can kill everyone with
an antibiotic and the only cells that
survive this are the persisters the guys
that were slow growing to begin
and since then it's been shown in many
other cases
that slow growth is protective okay and
there's different examples of this
there's an example in yeast from uh
Sasha Leslie and Mark Siegel
there's other examples of
resistance to phage
and there's a very nice review of all
this from Natalie and several other
people who've been working on
persistence so there's many cases and
and a lot going on in that um and so
what what this did the data I was just
showing you suggests was that the
lineage statistics suggests that that in
this case instead of just two states
okay persist or non-persistor there
could be a Continuum of growth rates
that this kind of fluctuating selection
is acting on
so the the last point I want to make is
that there's also a counter possibility
which is that the cells are directly
responding to this changing environment
just like I showed in in the cases of
responses to sugars
so the remaining question would then be
you know is the reason these slow
growing cells are seen in this
experiment is it because of selection on
the diversity of growth rates or is it
because the single cells are making a
switch to slower growth responsibly
already responsing for this so the final
question is really can we distinguish
these responses from selection
and so to address that
we've developed some Theory previously
on this how do you distinguish responses
from selection in these kinds of
experiments so the thought experiment we
came up with was imagine you can change
the historical conditions of your
experiments a little bit
so that all the growth rates are
increased by a small percentage so in
other words you take all the FIS that go
into your model or go into the actual
physiology and you imagine you could do
the experiments where you give everyone
a one percent bonus of fitness
and then you just rerun your experiment
right and you see has there been a major
change of the population structure or
not and so this would be a way to detect
the action of selection because you've
simply perturbed The Selective strengths
right and you're seeing whether there's
any change
so that's a thought experiment now to do
that you need to be able to manipulate
all these all these growth rates and an
experiments that's not going to be
robust but it turns out at least in
models you can show a nice relationship
between the average fitness of lineages
that you would have
upon the the change in the so this F
here is the fitness along lineages which
is just the integral of the growth rates
of cells along a lineage
and then averaged over the population
now you make a perturbation of the
growth rates and you can show that the
change in that average fitness of
lineages will be given by the standing
variance of Fitness in the population in
that experiment
so
um
further details on the theory side are
here but the general idea here is that
the lineage Fitness variance is is going
to allow us to detect in these kind of
experiments we expect the strength the
effective strength of selection as
balanced against physiology and response
so just to give you
a little intuitive feeling for that
imagine you have a two phenotype
switching model just two different
cellular States one is good in the first
environment the green and the reds are
good in the next environment and they
proliferate in this environment so if
you simulate this under two different
models where you either have responses
or you have just stochastic switching
then you'll get
different kind of histories and you can
see that these histories in which case
if you have a response they're really of
course nicely match the environment
right every time these are single cell
histories now from a simulation every
time you see a tick here the cell
divides in the lineage and the internal
state of the cell is shown in in the
solid curve and the background is
showing you the environment so you see
if the cells match the environment
they're doing well
um and these guys are responding so
they're switching every time the
environment switches these guys are
switching
and so if you calculate of course the
fitness of these lineages you're going
to get some value and you see that it's
quite tight because the cells are doing
very similar things if you have a
stochastic switch where you just
randomly can switch with some rate to
the different states you're going to see
something quite different in fact you
will see some lineages that do do
remarkably well right they almost look
like they're responding but in fact this
is just because of selection acting in
the population but at the same time you
can't do this perfectly well all the
time so parts of the lineage will also
look like they're making mistakes so
you'll go through the wrong state for
some time
okay and so the statistics here the
statistics of Fitness along these
lineages are going to have a much bigger
variance
okay so that's that's what we can use to
detect in principle to measure the
effect of selection small variance
versus large frames now in models we can
of course do everything and calculate
things analytically and things look nice
and experiments we basically need some
kind of control so we said can we find a
control where we have right we would
like to measure this distribution of
linear Fitness okay for example the
number of cell divisions in a lineage
across the population of fluctuating
environments we need to compare this
with something that we know is
responding that was our idea let's start
responding as a reference so we actually
found that you can actually see by eye
I'll show you in a moment that
cells filament responsibly under low
doses of antibiotic all right so if we
reduce the dose of antibiotic the cells
will actually filament and you'll see
that nicely here
um you're going to get carbon insulin
pulses and now as you go along every
time you see this word carb here look at
the cells and you see that they all
elongate
okay and you have to stare at this for a
while
okay and you see that every time you get
this carb they just all start elongating
a little bit
okay and then they do crazy things as
well so that's another story right they
do all these crazy things
um
so this was our idea was to say okay
let's look at the lineage Fitness
um for low dose versus high dose and in
Low Dose we believe there's a response
here and so what we find is that the
division rate along lineages in these
populations
comparing no antibiotics which is Rich
medium with low-dose carb in which we
think there's a response we see they
have very similar distributions their
variance is very similar the only
difference is that the mean division
rate goes down which makes sense of
course because in this case they're
experiencing antibiotics
so here we basically have what seems to
be a response the major difference is
just the shift of the mean of the
lineage division rate Distribution
on okay on the other hand if we look at
this High pulses of carbonicylene and
they're still delivered at the same time
window of 20 minutes and we do this the
same thing we look at the distribution
of cell division rates along lineages we
see see a wider variance and we see this
tale of low division rates here okay so
here it seems that the adaptation to
this high-dose electric environment
involves additionally some selection on
the whole Continuum of cellular growth
rates
okay
and so to to end I want to show you one
yeah why you say it's selection it is
from what I understood you just said
before when you get these long things
that's a few lack of divisions
so
it's not a selection in the sense of
Evolution Fitness it's just you're
messing with the population and you
change your distribution
right that's okay so that would be
possible in our case we can actually
look to see to what extent do filaments
contribute to the linear statistics and
we see that they're excluded from these
statistics
so the fact that we have slow growing
cells and fast growing cells appears to
not be due to going through this
filamentation state the filaments are
actually quite bad it turns out in
longest time scales in these devices so
you'll see that probably in this in this
next case so the last thing we've been
doing they're not genetically different
not genetically different right
everything is identical as well yeah so
selection here selection here is on the
phenotypic diversity that's generated
right okay so then we said let's go can
we can we engineer a situation where we
actually have states that we can we know
right are just stochastically switching
so I'm not going to go into the
molecular details but but we've done
this now with tetracycline resistance so
we actually have a a strain that
switches between on and off such that on
means that you're resistant to
tetracycline and often means you're not
and the switching rate between this on
and off is roughly 10 to the minus 2 per
generation so that's considered a super
fast stochastic switch in bacteria the
persistent switch for example is is 10
to the minus six okay so one in a
million switches this is the fastest
switch we know
um let's buy stable and so now you can
see here free switching in the mother
machine okay so the cell just switched
to Red the cell is green
it's making many many divisions
and eventually you'll see this is just
free switching you see this this red
cell filamented and now it's going to
die
this guy here is still green and
eventually I believe it switches to
two red if we wait a little bit longer
okay so that's just to be switching
without selection at all uh okay so you
see it switched and then eventually it's
going to filament and it'll die
um
and so now we said okay let's do this in
in these devices where we have small
populations and let's give pulses of
antibodies we can do this with longer
time skills or short these are quite
short time scales so every six minutes
we give them a pulse which just
basically means that we're we're tuning
The Selective difference between red
cells and green cells here and let's
just see what happens so initially we
start from growth in lb mainly the cells
are red after some cell divisions and
now they're basically experiencing this
fast look trading environment of six
minute tetracycline and you see that the
cells are struggling with this okay
they're going into filamenting States
here
things are looking quite bad
and there's even cell death here
now eventually a lineage here has made a
switch and it rapidly out competes all
the neighbors that's one One Sweep that
we see here and then you see this this
guy is just collapsing completely this
guy is now seemingly on the road to
Extinction as well by filamentation
this guy's also managed to to produce
green cells but this one somehow you'll
see in a moment gets rescued here
by another green cell switching
and this population now also makes a
switch back
okay so these cells can actually
are not deterministically going to win
the battle all right and if you switch
back you basically die all right and
these filaments are actually quite bad
as well because they push cells out of
the way so they take up space but
they're in fact useless so you see that
in a simple experiment we already have
right two states that we thought we were
controlling in a third state which are
these filaments which now the other
states have to fight against okay so
that that's going to be the end
um
so we've been measuring these uh single
cell dynamics of E coli populations and
I I showed that
you have real responses to fluctuating
sugars of course part of the physiology
of the bacterium memory then becomes an
important adaptation
um and then if you look at lineage
statistics and constant environments you
can actually predict we've been trying
to see what aspects of population
Dynamics can we predict and what are the
basic ingredients we need to know to
predict the Dynamics so in one case we
need to know whether there's memory okay
otherwise it's going to change the whole
the whole behavior in the case of of you
know if you make things as simple as
possible a constant environment You can
predict the statistics of these trees
and then if you go further and start
doing fluctuating stresses it seems that
these lineage behaviors could be quite
useful for inferring what's going on in
the experiments and then if you go
beyond it maybe we'll be able to measure
the strength of selection in these
heterogeneous populations
so I'd like to thank Guillen Lambert who
is doing most of the experiments you saw
and the very last section was done by a
student in the lab Wei Shan did the
stochastic switch and also want to thank
Toby burgmiller and calendula at ISD
Austria Who provided uh the black over
expression constructs for us and then
uichi is another collaborator that's
been using this device here that showed
you the constant lineages and constant
events
thanks a lot
about this very last experiment it seems
like there's a genuine spatial aspect
there also so it depends very much on
where the mutations kind of been taken
like where it occurs where they can be
successful has to occur somewhere in the
upper end
ometrios you know these rates and you
know less advantage of
a mutated one to predict Health
Administration yeah I fully agree I mean
we're now trying to develop a framework
to to analyze this data and to then
eventually make predictions and I agree
that space is going to take a major part
of this
um and if we could of course eliminate
these filaments we'd already make our
life a little easier but in fact they
also provide another sort of layer of
you know
um
there's pushing in this device right
there's these geometries
um you know do we have to model
everything to predict for long-term
Dynamics
uh hopefully not but we'll see
as you describe it
just by people
side effects
having helped you go about showing that
these memory phenomena or adaptations
hold on
yeah I would say as usual that's that's
quite difficult uh but in this case
these proteins
um the only the only thing I could say
to answer that would be that their
degradation rates are they're very very
stable proteins
so
um you know a lot of proteins in E coli
are stable but these are on the tail of
that distribution
so again if you make a very stable if
you increase the stability of the
protein you make it more likely for it
to be useful in this kind of passive
memory
it'd be interesting to look actually uh
if there was data on stability right and
then looking maybe at phylogeny and
stability that could be an interesting
Direction
absolutely I think you can you can do it
the only problem in these experiments is
the population sizes are small so uh you
wouldn't be able to generate I don't
think you'd be able to generate enough
medications to really see selection in
fact we like you know for these
experiments we can always show that the
cells did not attain a mutation by
simply at the end of the experiment
fluctuating them back to glucose okay
and then doing our flood training
experiment again and if they have to go
through lags again it means they haven't
learned how to just go in all
environments
um okay